as long as I'm president of the United
States Iran will never be allowed to
have a nuclear weapon good morning I'm
pleased to inform you the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime we
suffered no casualties all of our
soldiers are safe and only minimal
damage was sustained at our military
bases our great American forces are
prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world
no American or Iraqi lives were lost
because of the precautions taken the
dispersal of forces and an early warning
system that worked very well I salute
the incredible skill and courage of
America's men and women in uniform for
far too long all the way back to 1979 to
be exact
nations have tolerated Iran's
destructive and destabilizing behavior
in the Middle East and beyond those days
are over Iran has been the leading
sponsor of terrorism and their pursuit
of nuclear weapons threatens the
civilized world we will never let that
happen last week we took decisive action
to stop a ruthless terrorists from
threatening American lives at my
direction the United States military
eliminated the world's top terrorists
Qasim soleimani
as the head of the cuts force Salamone
was personally responsible for some of
the absolutely worst
atrocities he trained terrorists armies
including Hezbollah launching terrorist
strikes against civilian targets he
fueled bloody civil wars all across the
region he viciously wounded and murdered
thousands of US troops including the
planting of roadside bombs that maim and
dismembered their victims Salah mani
directed the recent attacks on US
personnel in Iraq that badly wounded for
servicemembers and killed one American
and he orchestrated the violent assault
on the US Embassy in Baghdad in recent
days he was planning new attacks on
American targets but we stopped him
solemn Annie's hands were drenched in
both American and Iranian blood he
should have been terminated long ago by
removing solemn a knee
we have sent a powerful message to
terrorists if you value your own life
you will not threaten the lives of our
people as we continue to evaluate
options in response to Iranian
aggression the United States will
immediately impose additional punishing
economic sanctions on the Iranian regime
these powerful sanctions will remain
until Iran changes its behavior